after going through type 1 and type 2
region definitions you could probably
guess what a type 3 region is going to
be so a type 3 type 3 region is a region
in three dimensions I'll just call it
our region is our sub 3 since we call
the other the type 2 region R sub 2 and
the type 1 region R sub 1 I'll call this
region R sub 3 R with a subscript 3 it's
going to be the set of all points in
three dimensions the set of all X YS and
Z's such that the X Z pairs X Z pairs
are a member of a domain I'll call this
domain D 3 D sub 3 and and let's put a
comma here Y is going to vary between
two surfaces that are functions of X and
Z so Y is going to be greater than or
equal to the surface I'll call it h1 of
X Z is going to be less than or equal to
y less than or equal to Y which is going
to be less than or equal to it's gonna Y
Y is gonna be bounded from above by the
surface h2 of X Z and once again let's
close our set notation so let's think
about whether some of these regions that
we already saw were type 1 and type 2
whether they're type 3 and then think
about what would not be a type 3 region
so let's go to this sphere what could be
our domain well the domain is a set of X
Z's and so it's going to be in the XZ
plane so over here our domain could be
this region right over here in the XZ
plane so I'll color it in it could be
that region right over there in the XZ
plane and then the lower bound on Y will
be the part that is behind the sphere in
this direction right over here is the
stuff it actually might be a little bit
hard to visualize since I'm redrawing on
top of it but and then the upper bound
on Y is going to be this side right over
here it's going to be this side right
over here
it's going to be the upper bound so all
of this is now is now going to be green
let me redraw the sphere just to make it
clear
so assuming that let me just draw
another coordinate axes if you know
another coordinate axes the backside of
the sphere in the y-direction so I guess
let's think of it this way so this is
the Hemis hemisphere mark this is the
halfway point for my sphere and once
again that's kind of the boundary of our
domain and then the backside let me do
the front side first
the front side wise upper bound that bh2
would be all of this business all of
this business right over here so this
would be h2 that I'm coloring in h2
would be the side that is facing in that
direction and let me see how well I can
color it and that didn't do a good thing
so h2 is all of this stuff out on this
side of the sphere and then h1 was a
lower bound on Y so it's gonna be that
side right over there and I could draw
it probably a little bit neater but
hopefully you get the point it would be
all of that side and then Y can vary
between those two and essentially fill
up the region we make the exact same
argument with the cylinder the cylinder
can be defined the same way so first of
all the sphere is a type 1 type 2 and
type 3 region it meets all of the
constraints this the cylinder at least
the way it was oriented there actually
any cylinder actually will also be a
type 3 region exact same argument so let
me let me draw my axes again let me draw
my axes again and here to make the
cylinder that we've been making our
domain could be a rectangle in the XZ
plane so our domain can be a rectangular
region and the X Z plane just like that
and then the lower bound on Y could be d
could be that side of the cylinder the
side facing in that direction right over
there that is the lower bound and then
the upper bound on Y could be the side
facing in that direction the upper bound
on Y would be this side this side right
right over there so once again this is
also a type 3 region by the same logic
this this
this one right over here this hourglass
can be a type 3 region the front side
the front side would be would be this
front side right over here all of this
including that stuff that I so it'd be
all of that and then the back side when
you think of in terms of why the
backside the backside would be that part
right over there right over there
and once again once again this could
also this could also be a type 3 region
the domain the domain let me draw the
domain would be kind of this cross the
boundary of the domain would be this
cross section right over here so the
boundary of our domain could be that
cross section right over there the lower
bound on Y would be the back half the
back half of this hourglass and the
upper bound on Y would be the front half
would be the front half right let me do
that in magenta color because I've been
using that or actually that green color
so the upper bound on Y would be this so
I guess you could say this right half
right over here
so what would not be a type 3 region
well if we just rotated this around like
that so let me just draw something that
is not a type 4 the region just to show
you that this definition does not
include everything so something that
would not be a type 4 reason for the
same argument as we've seen before for
type 2 and type 1 regions is an
hourglass where it's along the y-axis or
at least it's oriented this way it
actually does not have to be right
centered on the y axis but an hourglass
an hourglass that looks like this that
looks like this now all of a sudden the
Y can't be just expressed as being
between two surfaces that are functions
of X and Z you would have to break this
up in order to do that but you could
break break up this region into two type
three regions but the whole thing itself
is not a type 3 region so not not type 3